I said I I told the preachers we could
get deleted too 100% there's nothing
that I've seen from YouTube or the way
it operates that makes me think that
we're guaranteed a place on this
platform it just takes the one wrong
video and all of a sudden they looking
through the history and be like all
right that's enough justification get
rid of these guys right just probably
things got demonetized why do she get
demonetized according to the manual
review says your channel is not
currently able to learn after reviewing
your channel using a combination of
automated systems and human reviews we
found that it does not follow YouTube's
Channel monetization policies for
hateful or hurtful harmful or hateful
content apparently some um someone was
yelling that just pearly thing stopped
her 50-year-old sister in the street and
her school friends to ask them invasive
questions about um bedroom fun on her
YouTube channel she made several cuts of
the video and a sub rejected them to
abuse from the red pill
community so she was interviewing some
teenagers some some 14 and 15 year olds
is it surprising no no I think uh that
much we can just get out of the way
right away why is it not surprising Abba
um cuz I told you most of these red pill
goofballs are going to be gone the
moment I hear these guys saying women
should lose a right to vote I I don't I
don't think women should vote huh I
don't think women should vote I don't
think wom
should women shouldn't be allowed to
have a bunch of different rights if this
was pe's World I'd get rid of birth
control I'd ban it I think that the rude
of all evil the rude of all evil blah
blah blah this and that I already knew
the stuff was coming which is why I said
before if you guys are trying to
advertise your stuff and be making any
kind of money on YouTube this is never
going to last the moment you start
talking about stripping rights from a
whole group or 50% of the population
you're probably not going to last much
long you can feel how you want about
that
opinion but if I'm running a business
and I want to sell Advertiser and I got
a Creator who's saying strip the rights
of 50% of the population including the
demographic that most spends money when
it comes to advertisers there's no way
she's going to last I said the same
thing with the fresh and fit stuff it's
like I don't know how you could expect
YouTube to have to pay
you because they would be doing that at
the detriment of their own business they
would be losing money in order to pay
you because you are bad pressed for them
every time the CBC or any of these
Outlets write a piece on Pearl it's
about how bad she is and how the fact
that this stuff is growing on YouTube or
other platforms right so you're asking
these companies to pay you so they can
lose money mhm basically nobody would
run a business that way no not a single
[__] person and nobody is right
that's why you get demonetized they're
not losing any sleep over this cuz one
these kinding people don't make them
that much money they're not the prime
they're not what they use as pitch decks
for their advertisers they're not what
they use to say YouTube is such an
amazing Community this is like the dark
side of YouTube that like YouTube puts
away it's like the it's like the kid
living in the Attic that's what the red
pill Community is but all of a sudden
the kid living in the Attic is making
noise so nobody below can sleep they
start banging on the floor walking loud
at midnight and like you YouTube like oh
my God and and they waited to be fair
this should been crazy for 2 three four
years and YouTube Just but now YouTube's
like yo you guys been stepping too loud
making too much noise it's not even so
much that that you can't sleep at night
is that you can't invite nobody over no
you can't have no company because
they're making so much no you cannot
bring no company that's going to bring
something to your house because kid in
the Attic is crazy right now and
everybody knows about the kid in the
attic and now they pointing out you we
not go there there's a kid who the [__]
is that kid upstairs why you nobody
don't worry about it exactly so it just
don't look good so it's like listen kid
in the atct uh you're over 18 now you
need to move out the kid adct is just
yelling crazy [__] you just hear
sometimes he just like 16 year olds are
hotter than 29 year olds and like who's
that who said that oh that's just a kid
in the atct shut up boom boom boom boom
women should lose the right to vote who
said that it's it's just a kid in the
Attic who's that kid in the attic and
why the [__] do you get keep a kid in
the Attic yeah that's that's essentially
what the red Bill Community is um great
analogy by the way now whether it's
right or
wrong they didn't ban her they removed
her monetization basically saying you
don't get to earn money from us that's
the first
step they might not ever banned them I
think I think the monetization is
probably the smartest thing the most
effective thing you know um you draw
people to the platform but they don't
get to earn yeah well I fore what you're
saying yeah now does it suck that you
get something like this after not
receiving any strikes or anything like
that absolutely I could definitely see
how that would rub a lot of people the
wrong way but it's written it's written
that they don't have to necessarily give
you something yes YouTube wrote their
policies in a way that they can get rid
of anybody at any point exactly at the
same time the same people wrote their
own thing and you signed onto their
their platform listen I think there's a
lot of people who get demonetized or get
banned who it feels like it's an
ultimate Gray Zone just partly thinks is
not one of those people neither was
fresh and fair those are not people I
was surprised when they got removed
whether it was the false copyright
strikes against a bunch of people to get
their channels deleted whether it's her
bringing on Nick quentes to say a whole
bunch of stuff about black people and
Jews that you just can't be saying right
you think they were embellished upon I
think they're embellished yeah the same
way this sounds oh gosh oh boy ah
they're going to this sound this sounds
similar to the slavery stuff too cuz
that's that's literally they they the
founder of or the guy who made root said
I wanted a myth for my people to live by
if you want to be engaging in that kind
of stuff it's perfectly sensible for
YouTube saying we don't want you do I
feel bad for her absolutely
not do I think it's right that she got
demonetized if they didn't ban her I'm
not that I don't feel any type of way
about it I don't think anybody has the
duty to pay you if they don't want to
employ you do they have a duty to pay
her they don't have a duty to pay her I
guess argument would be these places are
such big platforms if they remove the
ability of these people to take make
money they're essentially censoring
people who leave a certain political
Spectrum those listen the thing is that
people that get from the 9 to5 to the
YouTube
game oft time have sometime a N9 of five
mentality I find for example when you do
a nine of five there is your your job is
subjected to
laws uh that they cannot just fire you
like that they have to pay you they have
to give you warnings they have to this
and that and whatever and the third uh
but of course you have to show off the
work YouTube is very different in the
sense that yeah they do pay you and you
kind of have an agreement with them you
they do pay you but you can if you don't
decide to show up to work you don't show
up to work you don't have a schedule if
you decide not to show up for a month
you don't show up for a month and then
when you do you do and any work any
other work they're not going to accept
that right uh it's not like a contract
where no you have to do not x amount of
videos and this and that like a 9 of5 uh
so it's not exactly the same thing
though I would I would say that when
they terminate this thing it's really
just a a partnersh ship that you have
you create videos and if they if they
boom in we give you something some out
of what we do it's like a a an
affiliation a partnership that whereever
like you know what that thing that you
do we're not going to affiliate
ourselves with that we don't feel like
this a good so you can keep on doing
your thing but we not want no part of it
it's not like a normal 95 work thing
yeah but I mean listen you guys you go
to rumble you can go to these other
platforms and and make it work there
nothing is Promised on this platform and
I'm not even saying this from some kind
of iron clown castle like I said I said
I told the preachers we could get
deleted too 100% there's nothing that
I've seen from YouTube or the way it
operates that makes me think that we're
guaranteed a place on this platform it
just takes the one wrong video and all
of a sudden they looking through the
history and be like all right that's
enough justification get rid of these
guys right that's how I honestly feel so
if our day comes I'm not going to be
shocked I'm not going to be surprised
will I be disappointed or said sure you
know you never want these things to end
but I've known what this platform is
from the jump the employees are never
going to run the employer they are never
going to run the company they're never
going to have that kind of power um so I
don't even know why people pretend
otherwise me this wasn't
surprising yeah I mean on the bright
side you know she she been losing
viewership for a long time her fan bases
diminish significantly in terms of
viewership and people giving it atten to
if she finds a way to succeed on other
platforms good for her but uh I don't
see her lasting so my thoughts on
it what do you think you invented um
something the other
day what was it oh yeah he
man man and Pros already on on on
Twitter being like Oh my God the Matrix
is a no bo that wasn't the Matrix that
was you He Man Yeah you see you every
time these red pillars want to do
something and then it comes back to bite
them in the ass they just be like The
Matrix
the matrix it's like it's you you
bringing on Nick Fuentes Matrix you out
here saying the most outlandish [__]
about people losing their rights the
matrix it's like you can never hold any
job saying a lot of this goofy ass [__]
you could never keep any job with this
much public profile okay and say this
goofy ass [__] there's no way try it try
try try being part of a tech
company and sitting down with dudes who
want the eradication of Jewish people or
stuff like that I wish you good luck
it's just that normal companies have
another department called HR YouTube
don't you get fired YouTube don't we
don't go through that HR process we it's
just that why should they tolerate
people in hoods running around doing all
this stuff they why of
course if you guys want to risk your
platforms to say dumb stuff that really
doesn't further your cause is just to be
extremist go ahead but don't go home
afterwards talk about the Matrix when
it's just your own [__] actions
coming back to bite you in the ass some
of y'all raising Savage dogs being
surprised when you get rabies afterwards
like [__] you bought the
[__] now the [__] part of you I don't
know just it's one of those things when
I'm like yeah it wasn't if it was
when who else is
left who else left from these red pill
people there's Donovan there's Rollo but
there're small they're too small they're
too small that's what I'm saying they're
smaller channels they're rats in the
Attic we we don't even hear
they don't make no noise well until
until they leave poop huh poop stains
poop drops maybe you can leave poop
drops in the addict as long as they
don't make it maybe maybe they going to
if he gets on CNN if he starts doing
news appearances then you got a
different story these people are too
Irrelevant for YouTube to even know they
exist M you know that's the truth you
need to actually be somewhat noticeable
or gain traction or have real News Press
I already said it before YouTube to feel
some type of way when you get news
coverage Pearl gets news coverage pearls
on Pierce Morgan pearls all going around
saying this goofy [__] I see what yeah
it's a different ball game when you are
that big right you you're some 10K Andy
you know you getting 10,000 they don't
give a [__] they don't care no yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but it is what it is man who's left
I don't know man who's left who is left
exactly all right let's know what you
guys think in the comments
below the end of the red pill we told
y'all it was coming